. The Small Business Administration released a
bunch of data about the businesses that received
money and IDL loans through the coronavirus
stimulus that was done some months ago.
And immediately, a very troubling pattern was
revealed in which Donald Trump's own businesses
and his son in law, Jared Kushner's own
businesses, benefited hugely from these funds.
Listen to some of what we've learned. Twenty five
PP loans worth more than three point six million
dollars were given to businesses with
addresses at Trump and Kushner real estate
properties paying rent to Trump and Kushner.
So that's indirect. Trump and Kushner benefited
from rent money that was obtained by their
tenants from PTP. That's number one number to
fifteen of those properties. Self
reported that they only kept one job
zero jobs or simply didn't report jobs retained
thanks to that money. Loans to Trump and Kushner
properties include a two million dollar loan
to the Triomphe Restaurant Corporation, located
inside Trump Hotel and Tower in New York City.
They reported that the money did not go to keeping
any jobs and then they closed down. I'll take the
money, then I'll close and I'll keep the money.
A company called Elby City Inc., which is
located at Kushner's Bungalow Hotel in Jersey,
received a loan for half a million
bucks and used that to keep some jobs
to tenants at seven twenty five Fifth Avenue,
which is Trump Tower, received more than one
hundred thousand dollars and kept only three jobs.
Three jobs total for tenants at the Kushner owned.
The infamous six six six five six six six
Fifth Avenue in Manhattan, received more than
two hundred thousand dollars and kept only six
jobs. And this entire thing has ended up being
a major cash grab for Trump and Kushner
directly and indirectly. Over one hundred loans,
we also learned, were made to companies where
no business name was listed in the field where
you're supposed to put in your business name
to get the money they either put in nothing or
like it listed a phone number or a date like that
could be a clerical error, but it also might not
be. I go and ask for a loan and they say, oh,
what's the business name? Oh, the business name is
June 17th, though he sure here have some money. So
first of all, none of this should come as a shock.
Obviously, Trump and his family, we're going
to take advantage of this money in any way that
they could. But meanwhile, remember that we're
supposed to believe we can't afford health care.
We can't afford to make sure nobody goes hungry.
We can't afford to forgive student loan debt.
We can't even afford a fifteen dollars an hour
minimum wage. We can't do mortgage and rent relief
during coronavirus. But look at all of this
money that is just flying around, much of which
should not be. Remember that right after the
stimulus was approved, Donald Trump removed the
person in charge of oversight of stimulus funds.
So it was obvious that they were going to do this
from day one. Trump and Kushner drifted the hell
out of the coronavirus stimulus money. But we're
supposed to believe Joe Biden is the socialist.
And that's where, you know, when you come around,
the truth really doesn't matter. When you
have nearly half the country so radicalized
by ideas like trust, Fox News and Joe Biden is a
socialist and Trump will fix all of your problems,
that it doesn't matter what the facts on the
ground are and understand the contrast here,
for example. I mean, listen, I've talked I've
told the story before, I'll tell it again,
I my lawyer and accountant contacted me when
the stimulus stuff was was announced and said,
you can get money, you can get money, and you
won't have to pay it back, like you could just
take money. And at the time, I mean, maybe
I did the wrong maybe I'm the naive one.
But at the time I said, listen, we've lost some
ad revenue, but I've gone to the audience and I've
said, listen, we we need your support. I get that
a lot of people are in tough financial situations,
but get a membership, pay five bucks a month if
you can afford it. And enough people did. Where
I said to our lawyer and accountant, let's not
do it. It just doesn't feel right. Like I don't
feel like we're really struggling in the way
that some of these small businesses that are
physical businesses rather than virtual
businesses, they're struggling really badly.
It feels as though any dollar I take might be
a dollar I'm taking away from somebody else.
And meanwhile, you have companies like the
ones that Trump and Kushner run and rent to
taking money, money, money, closing in some cases
and not having to pay the money back. And listen,
maybe I should have taken it right. I mean, I've
spoken on live streams about how in the last month
we've had hundreds and hundreds of people have
to cancel memberships because they've lost jobs
or didn't get jobs back or had hours cut because
of what's going on. Maybe I should have taken the
money, but then that would make me as bad as them,
wouldn't it? So it's a really it there's a lot of
ambiguity, but it certainly didn't feel like this
money was intended for me. It sure as hell should
not have been intended for billionaires who
can float their businesses on their own but
are choosing not to disgusting stuff. And I can
only imagine I can only imagine how much more
we're going to learn about this in the next few
weeks as we continue to comb through the data.
Let's take a quick break. We'll be
back after this. Much more to discuss
on this very important day.
The UK approving a coronavirus
vaccine for emergency use The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.